la querelle
josy ces personnes faisant sensation
rasteau patton
je m'appelle donc patrick swayze et j'ai
65 ans je suis marié avec une
réunionnaise et j'habite sur saint-andré
depuis donc que quatre ans maintenant
nous avons fondé l'association espace
hall réseau des coudes solidarité
personnes âgées
voulaient bien faire mais
pas les bons ad nous ça va
là je suis en train de faire un petit
peu le taxi collectif
c'est à dire que me prend dans leur
quasi peu toutes les tv personnes qui
ont demandé qui sont intéressés à venir
à cette petite journée d'animations
installez vous bien l'objectif de
l'association expressions c'est bien de
d'être d'accueillir de rendre visite et
d'organiser des sorties conviviales pour
des personnes âgées isolées de la
réunion
a donc engagé mais il est de ces choses
questions d'accès a produit dominant on
est comme une grande famille
la plupart du temps on est tout seul là
nous on
ne reçoit pas ce que parce qu'il
passe le pas moi
sa veuve est attendue tout seul
sa barbe mais la solitude comme souffler
ses lois supporter
ça nous remet un petit peu le moral en
place de discuter l'épisode manger
participer quoi regardez là lors de ce
jeu là on s'implique tous on s'amuse on
clique on tape fort sur la table oh non
au collège on plaisante et tout ça c'est
très convivial
ça m'apporte beaucoup de choix parce que
je vois des personnes âgées sont dans la
tristesse dans les airs au téléphone qui
me disent mes patrons
me ne pas sortir mais ne connaît plus
personne n'a plus de monde qui vient
voir loin et quand je les vois avec un
sourire tranche papaye c'est du gâteau
et j'allais dire c'est formidable là
c'est du vrai partage